hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about
a media that you can use in the lab to
grow certain bacteria in certain
situations and that media that we're
talking about today
is called chocolate auger and i always
tell my students no it does not
actually have chocolate in it it's just
a brown color
and that's why it's called chocolate
auger so let's start talking about this
medium
it is non-selective meaning that
it will allow
pretty much anything to grow but it is
enriched
and that is in order to support the
growth
of certain bacteria that we consider to
be fastidious
you can think of these bacteria as being
kind of picky
um so i'll write that right here they're
kind of picky they don't grow very
easily
they won't grow at all if put on some
more common
uh types of lab media that are not
enriched
to support their growth and so the
chocolate auger
is made of lysed red blood cells
i'm going to put a little star right
here the reason that the
uh the chocolate auger has that brown
color
is because of the lysed red blood cells
and this is what makes it different
what makes chocolate auger different
from
a kind of normal blood agar is the fact
that the red blood cells are lice
and so they are lysed and this provides
two important things first it provides
iron
for these fastidious bacteria to grow
and
it provides a few different growth
factors that are present
inside those red blood cells and
available in the media once those red
blood cells have been lysed
and that is the coenzyme nad
sometimes called nad and another uh
growth factor called hemen
h-e-m-i-n and so these two growth
factors
sometimes people will use a more
kind of antiquated term for them and
that is factor
five i'm going to write a v here like a
roman numeral v
so that's factor five and then a human
is known as factor
ten always again with roman numerals
so i'm gonna make the the roman numeral
x there for the roman numeral 10.
and so nad known as factor five human
known as factor 10
and sometimes you'll still encounter
those names in the literature
and so now let's talk about the kinds of
bacteria
that we're commonly trying to grow
basically which
fastidious bacteria are we trying to
grow on chocolate auger
and this is different species of the
genus
mysteria
and the genus haemophilus
so these two genera nasseria and
haemophilus species of those two
these are the fastidious bacteria that
we're trying to grow with the chocolate
auger
and now you'll probably remember me
saying at the beginning non-selective
meaning that there are a lot of things
that can grow on chocolate auger
and so specifically we're using it to
look for the growth of nesiria species
and hemophilia species
in body fluids that are typically
sterile
so think of things like blood
cerebrospinal fluid
body fluids like that that are typically
sterile
to see if there is an infection in a
patient
an infection caused by one of these
types of bacteria
and then you can identify the specific
type of nasseria or haemophilus growing
on the chocolate auger
uh by different characteristics
in the colonies that are growing on the
auger so you can identify species based
on things like size
color consistency margins that kind of
things this is just a visual inspection
of the colonies to identify
you know which species of nesiria or
which species of haemophilus is present
in that body fluid and causing an
infection in that patient
now we can also modify chocolate auger
to make it selective for the purposes of
isolation and what that means is that
if you have if you're drawing a sample
from
a a site in the body for example that is
not typically sterile
think like the mouth or the nose um
you can have some modified
types of chocolate auger that will
prevent the growth
of most other bacteria allowing for
isolation of some of these specific
species of nasseria and haemophilus
so let's first talk about thayer martin
auger this is one of our modifications
and this is chocolate auger that is
supplemented with a supplement sometimes
called vcn
this is an acronym the v stands for
vancomycin
vancomycin of course is an antibiotic
and
it is used to inhibit
the gram-positive bacteria
so that's why it's being added to the
chocolate auger to inhibit
the growth of gram-positive bacteria
the next one the c stands for colistin
this is a specialized compound that
inhibits the growth of
most gram-negative bacteria while
allowing the syria
to still grow so nesteria species are
um they're generally resistant to
the effects of colistin so colistin i'm
just going to say it inhibits
most
gram-negative bacteria
[Music]
again while allowing some of these
species of this area to still grow
and then the n in vcn stands for nice
statin
and that is an anti-fungal
so it inhibits fungi
from growing so by supplementing the
chocolate auger
with the vcn thus the vancomycin
cholesterol and nystatin
you can inhibit the growth of this
unwanted
excuse me of these unwanted bacteria and
fungi
and this allows the isolation of nesiria
gonorrhea and sinisteria meningitidis
another modification to make selective
to make chocolate auger selective for
isolation is chocolate auger with
basatracin
so i'll underline that right there basic
tracing is another antibiotic it's a
it's a broad spectrum antibiotic that is
meant to inhibit
the growth of um virtually
all bacteria and chocolate auger and
basic tracing
is used to isolate hemophilus influenzae
i actually had some
students win a science fair
recently by using chocolate auger with
basic tracin to look at
the groups of people that had age
influenzae in their nose
and how this could be used to um
look at that that group's susceptibility
or resistance to
being infected with influenza so that
was a pretty cool project
if you are interested in other kinds of
growth media i have
several different types of
videos on the different kinds of media
that you might use to select
for one bacterium or select for another
bacterium
and those are all in a playlist the
bacterial media bacterial growth media
playlist and i will link to that in the
description
that's it for today and thanks for
watching biology professor